First, though,
CNN's Ryan Young in Nashville
for us tonight.
And Ryan,
you spoke to Representative Jones
after he was reappointed.
So what did he tell you?
John, this was amazing to see.
We saw it all play out
right there in front of us.
Not only from city council
and then the marched down the street here
to the state capitol.
But all these thousands of people
showed up
to be here for a rally
to walk up the stairs
here to the state capitol.
And this all played out right for us
right there at the state capitol.
That's where he was
sworn in on those steps.
People were cheering. They were yelling.
They said they wanted their voices
to be heard.
And let's just say
this, just as Owens says,
he was energized by what happened.
And he said
the fight is not over just yet.
Take a listen.
Today, we send a clear
message to Speaker Cameron Sexton
that the people will not allow his
his crimes against democracy to happen
without challenge.
We are calling on House Speaker Cameron
Sexton to resign as speaker of the House.
He is an enemy of democracy.
And, John,
more than a thousand people
marched with him
all the way from city hall
and then walk through that front door.
And then, of course, when they swore him
right there on the steps that he went
and got his old plaque back
and went into that seat.
The battle here
won't stop for quite some time
because that remember,
they were appointed back to the seat
and we're told
there will have to be a special election.
So this process is not over just yet.
But you can just tell by the energy
that's surrounding the city right now
that they believe
they have finally sort of cracked
the surface in terms
of getting people to understand
what's going on in the state
in this process tonight
that you just saw
was for Representative Jones.
In a moment,
I'm going to speak
to Representative Justin Pierson.
What's the timetable
for his possible reinstatement?
Well, they are talking about Wednesday.
So, of course,
there was this talk
across the state
about whether or not
what could happen here
at the state house
might affect
Shelby County
and whether or not funds
would be held back.
But now we're hearing,
we believe that
what will happen in Memphis,
Will Pierson will be get a chance
to come back to the house.
But he was here today
to energize the crowd
and see both these young men
standing together strong,
addressing this crowd.
The crowd came to hear these two people.
At some point,
it sounded like they were addressing
like a rock concert
because it was so loud
here with
people amped up
and pumped up to go into the statehouse.
People admitted to us today
they had never been to the state capitol,
but they wanted to be here
to support these two young men
who they felt like were unjustifiably
kicked out of the statehouse last week.
Two elected officials
both expelled, one now reinstate dated.
Ryan Young, thank you very much.
Now to the other.
Joining us now,
the man in question, Representative
Justin Jay Pierson.
Representative,
thanks so much for being with us.
Your reaction
tonight to your colleague
being reappointed
to the Tennessee legislature
and are you confident
that you will be reinstated on Wednesday?
First, I want to
honor the
victims of another mass
shooting in our country in Louisville
and the mass shooting here in Nashville
at the Covenant School
that elevated this real conversation
for the need to end gun violence
in our communities.
That's the issue that we got expelled
for standing up
against the National Rifle Association
and standing up against gun lobbyists
and so on.
I still mourn
with everyone who is still mourning.
And while we celebrate
our brother, Representative Jones,
and the democratic process of people
who have decided
that we are
tired of the injustice
of the Republican majority
of the Tennessee Statehouse
who are deciding
that they are going to have a mob ocracy
rather than a democracy.
We continue this fight and this movement
and this momentum toward justice.
How do you think you will be received
given that you were voted out
by a super majority if you are
and you are reinstated on Wednesday?
How do you think that Republican
majority will greet you?
I don't know exactly
how the Republican Party
is going to greet us into the future.
What I do know is that the people
who are advocating for change,
the people
who want to see an end to gun violence,
the people who are asking
that our legislators
do something,
the people who continue to march
and to protest
and who continue
to show up, the children
and the teenagers and the grandmothers
who the Republican Party called
insurrectionists who were peaceful
protesters are going to continue
to demand that justice happen.
And if I have the opportunity
to serve the people of Memphis
and Millington in Shelby County
as District 86
is representative in this appointment
and hopefully in an elected office,
I promise to elevate
the issues of our community and not stop
because the issues of justice
in the state of Tennessee
and a state that too often is silencing
those who are marginalized,
that is intentionally expelling
voices of people
who are saying
we have to do something about gun
violence, who are exercising
our First Amendment
that is given to us in the Constitution.
If it is the will of God
and the people in Shelby County
for me to serve,
I promise to continue to do so.
And I'm going to do it,
I believe,
with all of the people who continue
to show up for us in this moment
who are saying it's enough
and now is the time
for us to create change in this state.
Talk to me about
maybe the split feelings
that you brought up yourself
to see your colleague reinstate
voted today,
but also today to see a mass shooting
where four people were gunned down
in a neighboring state.
It's a sobering reality that we are in
that we are not doing enough
to prevent gun violence.
It is a sad
and another tragic day in our country
where we know the decisions of people
in power,
decisions of people
who could actually do something
to prevent gun violence
in our schools,
in our banks, in our communities
by preventing guns
from getting in the hands of individuals
who have them.
The people in positions of power
are refusing to act.
And it is a tragedy
that that is our reality.
And at the same time,
we are seeing people
who are pleading for democracy
to work, the people
and Nashville Metro Council,
the people in Shelby County
that the county commission.
Our communities
are pleading for democracy
to work in order that we might be able
to effect the change that we need.
And so, yes,
it is multiple emotions, a celebration,
and of the determination
of a people who want to see justice
happen with representative Jones
being receded.
And it also a painful moment
of recognition
that our legislators and people
like Cameron Sexton
and the Republican Party
in Tennessee
and across the South in this country
are not doing nearly enough
to prevent guns
from getting in the hands of people
and doing all of the holistic work
of gun prevention
that is necessary
in places across our communities,
including in Memphis and Millington.
My district,
very quickly, if you are reinstated,
would you engage in the type of behavior
that Republicans say
they expelled you for?
Would you demonstrate again like you did
on the House floor?
I believe that our actions
were wholly justified
and that even though
we broke a rule of decorum,
we stood up and we spoke for people
who needed us to speak for them.
Voices of children and adults
who will never be able to speak again.
And so I believe what we did was right
and it was for right.
And that we have a responsibility now.
And our legislators
in this
legislature, legislator
now need to do more to stop it in
gun violence.
It is preventable
and we aren't doing nearly enough.
Would you
break the rules of decorum again
to make that point?
Sometimes rules have to be broken
in order
for the people
who've been pushed to the periphery
to be brought
to the center of the conversation.
Sometimes rules have to be broken
in order
for the voices
that have been marginalized, told
that they are voiceless to be heard.
Sometimes rules have to be broken
in order for us to create justice.
And if that is what's necessary
for justice to happen, then
that is what is necessary.
And as you see
District 86 in our community,
we're willing to risk it all
for people to be safe.
We're willing to risk it all for justice
to roll down like waters
and righteousness
like a never flowing stream.
And we will not stop
events like we have not seen happening
in Nashville before our eyes.
Representative Pierson,
we do appreciate you
being with us tonight.
Look forward to speaking with you again.
Thank you.
We'll keep fighting.